je vous présente ici un album
d'aquarelles et de dessins réalisés par
jean baptiste louis dumas cet album
d'aquarelles et de dessins a été acquis
par les archives départementales de la
réunion en 1995 les aquarelles et les
dessins ne sont pas signées mais le
cahiers manuscrits qui les accompagnent
nous permettent de savoir que les
aquarelles et dessins ont été réalisés
en 1830 jean baptiste louis dumas est né
en 1792
polytechnicien et ingénieur des ponts et
chaussées il effectue une carrière en
métropole
en 1827 répondant aux sollicitations de
quelques-uns des principaux
propriétaires de l'île et désireux
également de travailler dans un pays
qu'ils qualifient de 9 il parcourt l'île
bourbon
il arrive en qualité de chef du service
des ponts et chaussées il débarque à
bourbon le 12 juin 2008 128 son travail
consiste alors essentiellement en
l'amélioration de la route royale qui
ceinturait lille en 1829 dumas propose
les plans d'une nouvelle église et d'un
hôpital militaire pour embellir la ville
de saint denis
jean baptiste louis dumas va rester deux
ans à l'île bourbon il y souffrent du
climat jusqu'à y perdre sa santé ce
qu'il oblige à renoncer à ses ambitieux
projets et a quitté l'île en 1830 de son
court séjour nous conservons cependant
quelques pièces administratives et
l'album aujourd'hui présenter
cet album fut conçu pour l'essentiel
dans les semaines précédant son retour
en métropole
libéré de ses charges professionnelles
il peut ainsi saisir sur le vif ses
personnages familiers de la société
coloniale du dix neuvième siècle avant
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
et qui ont laissé si peu de traces le
commandeur le joueur de bob et le
porteur d'eau indien le noir de pioche
la repasseuse la cuisinière et ainsi de
suite toutes ces figures isolé sur des
fonds neutres constitue un témoignage
intéressant sur l'esclavagé à la réunion
ses aquarelles et dessins donnent
également avoir des habitations et des
paysages de bourbon ces représentations
au très précis sont aujourd'hui des
témoignages de grande valeur de retour
en métropole
la carrière de jean baptiste louis dumas
le conduira dans la loire en 1831 puis
au mans il mourra en 1849 noyé dans les
eaux de la sarthe
une cinquantaine de ses aquarelles et
dessins sont consultables en ligne sur
le site de l'icône hotech historique de
l'océan indien
on